bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
soy luis muñoz y en esta ocasión vamos a
viajar hasta san juan puerto rico para
hablar con manuel natal albelo abogado y
político puertorriqueño coordinador del
movimiento victoria ciudadana en 2020
quedó en segundo lugar en las elecciones
a la alcaldía de san juan' precisamente
la capital de puerto rico está
celebrando sus 500 años de historia un
acontecimiento que ha contado con la
visita del rey de españa felipe sexto en
una invitación que ha generado rechazo
manuel natal bienvenido a la entrevista
de france 24
muchas gracias por la oportunidad manuel
ha sido muy crítico con la invitación al
monarca español el en su viaje ha
reivindicado el modelo de presencia de
españa en américa y además ha llegado a
decir que en san juan se respira
hispanidad quería preguntarte manuel de
ser alcalde le hubiese recibido al rey
de españa
quizás es importante que pongamos en
contexto a las personas que nos pueden
estar viendo de la situación no
solamente política sino económica de
puerto rico puerto rico fue por más de
400 años una colonia de españa y
continúa siendo una colonia de los eeuu
por más de 120 años puerto rico se
encuentra en su crisis económica más
grande en su historia moderna en una
crisis fiscal y social que requiere de
que quienes tienen el privilegio de
ocupar puestos de liderato en el país
tengan las prioridades claras yo creo
que hay que dar un paso hacia atrás no
es si se hubiese recibido a alguien y si
se hubiese no solamente invitado en este
caso al rey felipe sino también se
hubiese incurrido en el desembolso de
cientos de miles de dólares en fondos
públicos para una actividad como ésta y
mi respuesta directa y contundente es
que hay otras prioridades que zhang huan
tiene otras necesidades que fuese la de
costarle un viaje a un monarca a puerto
rico mucho menos en condiciones en las
que lo que reafirmó fue el modelo sabor
de puerto rico y eso obviamente en
nuestro caso lo rechazamos también has
hecho un repaso contextual y en ese
repaso también es importante destacar
que coincidiendo con la visita del rey
de españa ha habido un derribo de la
estatua de juan ponce de león el que
fuera el primer gobernador español en la
isla que además a éste le ha llamado en
twitter genocida quería preguntarte cuál
es la relación que esperarías que
tuviese españa con américa y más
concretamente con puerto rico dado este
pasado colonial pero yo creo que la
historia está ahí para evaluarla para
entenderla para aprender sobre ella y
obviamente también en aquellos casos
para no repetir aquello que
evidentemente hoy no nos representa y yo
muy bien por un lado puedo entender que
no podemos medir en la historia pasada
quizá con las con las circunstancias o
los principios o los valores que hoy
tenemos pero si podemos buscar
asegurarnos que esa historia se ponga en
contexto y yo creo que en el caso
puntual de españa como es el caso
eeuu es importante que haya un
reconocimiento de lo que significó para
el pueblo puertorriqueño los 400 años de
coloniaje en español y los sobre 120
años de coloniaje estadounidense y yo
creo que ese reconocimiento nos
permitiría tanto al pueblo
puertorriqueño como a la nación
estadounidense como a la nación española
el poder tener unas relaciones que sean
relaciones más fructíferas y en ese
sentido yo creo que la visita de el rey
ha creado una situación en puerto rico
que no es distinta a las que están
surgiendo en otros países en
latinoamérica en los eeuu de ir sobre
estos monumentos o esta estatua y lo que
simbolizan en los eeuu por ejemplo se
han removido estatuas que están
vinculados a personas que tuvieron un
activismo en todo lo que tiene que ver
con la historia racial y racista de los
eeuu en latinoamérica y en otras partes
del mundo también ocurre con figuras que
han tenido historias
imperiales y colonialista genocidas en
algunos casos y yo creo que hay que
tener un debate sobre verdad qué
significan en el presente esta figura y
tienen que haber procesos de discusiones
colectivas para poder asegurarnos que se
pongan en el contexto que le hace
justicia en este caso al pueblo
puertorriqueño
como bien has estado comentando abogadas
por un proceso de colonización no sólo
con españa sino también con eeuu no
piensas que también esta visita del
monarca español y la apertura de
relaciones comerciales puede darle una
mayor autonomía comercial a puerto rico
o bien también es una visita que está
auspiciada que está validada desde
washington bueno más varias cosas en el
caso de puerto rico
hay un mandato creciente del pueblo de
puerto rico que la relación colonial que
hemos sostenido con los eeuu y que se
formalizó en un pacto entre puerto rico
y el congreso de los eeuu en el 1952 es
una relación que ya no le sirve bien al
pueblo de puerto rico es una relación
críticamente colonial en donde la
soberanía del pueblo de puerto rico se
encuentra en el congreso de los eeuu y
no en la gente del pueblo de puerto rico
yo tuve el privilegio de ser miembro de
la cámara de representantes de puerto
rico por cerca de ocho años en los
últimos cuatro años fueron bajo la
imposición de una junta de control
fiscal sobre el fuego sobre el pueblo de
puerto rico con unos individuos que
fueron nombrados por el presidente de
los eeuu que tienen más poder que los
propios funcionarios electos por el
pueblo de puerto rico eso obviamente es
una relación que no puede continuar y
hay un mandato del pueblo de puerto rico
de comenzar un proceso de
descolonización claro el pueblo de
puerto rico hay que reconocerlo hay
divisiones en cuanto hacia donde nos
debemos mover hacia nos debemos mover
hacia una independencia hacia una
relación de libre asociación con los
eeuu o inclusive hacia la integración o
la estadidad con el gobierno eeuu aquí
lo interesante también podría decir a la
segunda parte de tu pregunta es que esto
es un gobierno la administración de
turno actual tanto municipal como a
nivel nacional es una administración
vinculada a un partido en puerto rico
que favorece la anexión y que por mucho
tiempo ha criticado el que otras
administraciones busquen establecer
relaciones internacionales con otros
países que no sea el propio gobierno
estadounidense así que yo creo que hay
un poco también de hipocresía son 16
años de depresión económica en puerto
rico hay más del 40 por ciento de la
población viviendo bajo el umbral de la
pobreza una gran pérdida de población
joven y también un gran control como has
estado comentando de eeuu sobre el
estado libre agregado que supone puerto
rico
como se puede revertir esto y si todo
también es por culpa de estas dinámicas
coloniales bueno en el caso de puerto
rico ha habido también unas
manifestaciones que se han hecho sentir
a través del voto en puerto rico por
muchísimos años podemos hablar casi de
70-80 años
han existido dos partidos que se han
turnado el poder que se han alternado el
poder es uno que es el que defiende la
relación actual colonial del estado
libre asociado y otro que defiende una
relación de anexión con los eeuu en
tiempo reciente un sector creciente y
mayoritario del pueblo de puerto rico se
ha dado cuenta que estos partidos no
representan los mejores intereses del
pueblo de puerto rico y el pueblo ha
sabido votar de forma distinta victoria
ciudadana es un movimiento emergente que
precisamente responde a ese reclamo de
una mayoría del pueblo de cambio de
entender que lo que hemos hecho no ha
funcionado ni para atender el tema del
statu es decir la relación política
entre puerto rico y los estados unidos
ni para atender el resto de los temas
que nos afectan en nuestro diario vivir
la educación la seguridad la salud el
desarrollo económico entonces eso obliga
al pueblo de puerto rico a repensarse la
forma en que nos hemos organizado y
buscar entonces espacios comunes para
adelantar una agenda de descolonización
una agenda de cambios de progreso y eso
se está dando en puerto rico hay que
recordar que apenas hace poco más de dos
años el pueblo de puerto rico se
movilizó para remover a un gobernador
que no le estaba sirviendo bien a
nuestro pueblo así que yo creo que hay
un despertar de nuestro país que va a
ayudar no solamente a ponerle fin a esta
relación colonial que tenemos con los
eeuu sino también a asegurarnos que
independientemente la naturaleza no
colonial o territorial prevalezca la
equidad la justicia la solidaridad y que
haya un desarrollo económico que permita
a aquellos que están tenido que ir
regresar a puerto rico ya los que
estamos poder quedarnos sin embargo
empecé a ser más pobre que cualquier
estado de estas el pib de puerto rico es
el mayor de américa latina nos ha
beneficiado también la isla de esta
relación con eeuu pero tenemos que ver
entonces también lo que son las tasas de
crecimiento lo que son otros factores
que inciden sobre donde estábamos y
dónde estamos en este momento la
realidad del caso es que las ventajas
que una vez existieron de la relación
política entre puerto rico y estados
unidos hoy ninguna de ellas existe
inclusive algunas de las cuales le daban
a puerto rico una ventaja competitiva
por la relación entre puerto rico y los
eeuu en un mundo globalizado de esas
ventajas ya hoy no existen y nos hemos
quedado con lo peor de dos mundos antes
el estado libre asociado
popularmente en puerto rico- el partido
que lo defendía utilizado a la frase de
que el estado libre asociado era lo
mejor de dos mundos
a lo más cercano la estadidad sin ser
parte de los eeuu es lo más cercano a la
autonomía es sin perder esa relación hoy
en día tenemos lo peor de los dos mundos
porque no tenemos los poderes para tomar
decisiones propias ni tenemos la
representación en el gobierno
estadounidense para poder establecer la
pauta o contribuir a la toma de
decisiones y yo creo que cuando miramos
alrededor lo que está ocurriendo en
otros países hoy en el país hermano de
la república dominicana el crecimiento
económico que ha tenido claro hay un
tema de desigualdad social que es
preocupante pero hay unos indicadores
que demuestran que mientras puerto rico
en momento se ha quedado estancado en
otros ha perdido terreno hay otros
países hermanos que han prosperado y yo
creo que si bien es cierto que nuestra
relación política no es la culpable de
todas las situaciones que se viven en
puerto rico
esa relación limita las posibles
soluciones a las crisis que atravesamos
muy rápidamente una última pregunta en
las elecciones de 2020 para la alcaldía
de san juan te apoyo advani esto me hace
reflexionar sobre si hay una nueva
generación en puerto rico con unas
demandas diferentes y que buscan esa
autodeterminación que también estás
estado reclamando
sin duda alguna hay una nueva generación
que no responde a las tradiciones
políticas de votar por un partido u otro
de aquellos que han tenido el privilegio
de gobernar en el pasado y esa
generación ha tenido influencia en
generaciones mayores y si algo bonito
que vimos en la elección del 2020 fue
personas mayores adultos mayores que uno
tenía comparaciones con demencia mira
caramba yo me he sentado a hablar con
mis miedos yo me he sentado a hablar con
mis bisnietos y entendido que tenemos
que hacer las cosas de forma distinta
así que por eso yo voy a salir a votar
en mi caso como pasado candidato a la
alcaldía de san juan' yo te voy a dar el
voto porque quizás a mí no me queda
mucho tiempo en este país a mis nietos y
yo quiero asegurarme que tengan un mejor
país y si queremos tener las cosas
distintas en este país tenemos que votar
distinto así que si hay un cambio hay un
cambio generacional y yo creo que
nuestro país tiene más futuro que pasado
muchísimas gracias manuel un placer
hablar contigo muchas gracias por la
oportunidad y muchas gracias a nuestra
audiencia por ver nos pueden seguir más
contenidos como éste en france 24 y
frank 34 punto com
[Música]
bien